تجدد العنف فور انتهاء الغنه في السودان
وترفضان الحل العسكري والصراع
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه تطلب مجددا تمكين
خبرائها من الوصول لخزانات كخوفكا التي
تبرد محطه
في اوكرانيا
استطاعا للرائي يظهر ان سبعه واربعين من
المشاركين يرون ان تهم الوارده في قضيه
ترامب ذات دوافع سياسيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الهمباء من العربيه قالت السعوديه
الولايات المتحده في بيان مشترك ان الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه ظهرها سيطره
فعاله على قوتهما خلال هدنه الاربع
والعشرين ساعه الاخيره
ودارت السعوديه والولايات المتحده بشده
تجدد العنف السودان فور انتهاء الهدنه
واكد طرفان استعدادهما لاستئناف المباحثات
اذا تقيد طرفا الصراع باعلان جده كما كان
ان الحل العسكري للصراع في السودان غير
مقبول
وكان براسر العربيه فاد بتجدد القصف
المدفعي تجاه مركزات الدعم السريع في ام
درمان
فيما تجددت الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
في الخرطوم واستخدم فيها الجيش السوداني
اسلحه ثقيله وتمحورت بحسب مراسل العربيه
في وسط وغرب الخرطوم وفي ام درمان مشيرا
الى استخدام اسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه خلال
الاشتباكات في محيط جسر الحلفايه في مدينه
بحري شماليه الخرطوم حيث توالت الانباء
حول سيطره الجيش السوداني عليك
المتحدثه الاقليميه باسم اللجنه الدوليه
لصليب الاحمر كانت قد ذكرت ان فرق الحمايه
التابعه للجنه في السودان تستقبل اتصالات
دائما للابلاغ عن حالات فقدان لافراد من
العائلات السودانيه منذ بدء الصراع قبل
شهرين وبحسب المتحدثه لن تتوقف البلاغات
حتى الان مع استمرار عمليات البحث عن
المفقودين المبلغ عنهم مشدده ايضا على ان
عمليات التقصي دونها عوائق عديده ابرزها
الاقتتال المستمر وشحوا الامكانيات
والموارد الطبيه حيث تعيق عمليات التعرف
على الجثامين او انتشالها
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادر العربيه بسعاده الجيش
الاوكراني ثلاثه بلدات وقريتين جنوب شرق
البلاد واظهر الجيش مشاهد لجنوده يحملون
العالم الاوكراني في بلده بلاجو دانتي
التابعه لمقاطعه دونات
يسعدني اعلان تحرير قريه بلاغو داتني
بمنطقه دونيتسك وكانت عمليه ناجحه ونحن
الان نشهد النتائج الاولى للهجوم المضاد
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الاوكراني
العمل بدا بالفعل في تحقيق او تحقيق تجريه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في تدمير سد
نوفا كاخوفكا والفيضانات الهائله التي
نتجت عنه واضاف ازلاسكي في خطابه المسائيل
المصور ان ممثلي المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
زاروا منطقه خرسون في الايام الاخيره كما
قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه في اليوم الاول
بعد الكارثه ارسل مكتب المدعي العام
الاوكراني طلبني الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بشان التحقيق في هذه الكارثه وبدا
العمل بالفعل واضاف ان من المهم ان يرى
خبراء قانونيون دوليون تداعيات الكارثه
ومنها حوادث قصف المناطق التي غمرتها
المياه وقال مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان ثلاثه
اشخاص قتلوا يوم الاحد الماضي في قصف
الروسي لقوارب كانت تنقل من تم اجلائهم من
المدنيين
في الاونه الاخيره زار ممثلون محكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه منطقه خرسون في اليوم
الاول بعد الكارثه ارسل المدعي العام طلبا
الى مكتب المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بشان التحقيق في هذه الكارثه وقد
بدا العمل بالفعل من المهم جدا ان يروا
ممثلوا العداله الدوليه بام اعينهم عواقب
هذا الهجوم الارهابي الروسي وسمعوا شخصيا
ان الارهاب الروسي مستمر ويستمر القصف
الاكثر وحشيه على المنطقه التي غمرتها
الفيضانات
قررت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه طلبها
بالوصول الى الموقع الذي يتم فيه قياس
منسوب المياه في خزان سد كخوفك المستخدمه
لتبريد مفاعلات محطه جبروجيا للطاقه
النووي اضافه الوكاله ان خبرائها
الموجودين بشكل دائم في المحطه يحتاجون
الى الوصول الى موقع قربه محطه النوويه
لتوضيح سبب تباين الكبير الملاحظ بين
القياسات المختلفه
قالت صحيفه واشنطن بوست نقلا عن مصادر
مقربه من الدوائر الدبلوماسيه الروسيه ان
الهجوم المضاد وضع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين في دائره
خطيره سياسيا
تشتعل الجبهات وتاتي اقوى الاشارات الرئيس
الاوكراني يتحدث عن تنفيذ عمليات هجوميه
ودفاعيه مضاده وفي موسكو يلقي الهجوم
المضاد بثقله على الكرملين وتتزايد
المخاطر السياسيه على الرئيس الروسي وفق
تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه ووفق
الصحيفه فان موسكو امام جبهه قتال على
الارض واخرى داخليه متوتره
ميدانيا تثير القوه الناريه للاسلحه
الغربيه الاوكرانيه توترا النخب الروسيه
كما تخشى احتماليه قطع جسر كيرش شريان
الحياه بين روسيا وشبه جزيره القرم اضافه
الى انتقال القوات الاوكرانيه من
زابوريجيا نحو ميليتوبل وصولا الى بحر
ازوف
سيناريوهات تاتي في وقت تلقي الهجمات على
موسكو بالجروب الحدوديه وما يثار عن
انقسام بين قاده عسكريين روس بظلالها على
الداخل الروسي وضع تقول واشنطن بوست انه
يثير تساؤلات حول قدره بوتين على السيطره
عليه اذ بدت علامات التوتر المتزايد تظهر
حين اعلن عضو مؤثر في البرلمان الروسي
مقرب من المخابرات الروسيه ان روسيا فشلت
حتى الان في جميع اهدافها وبدا لافتا ايضا
ما نقلته الصحيفه عن مصدر مقرب من الدوائر
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه قوله ان هناك اشارات
متواضعه ظهرت على ان موسكو قد تكون مستعده
لتقديم بعض التنازلات يزداد التوتر ايضا
وفق الصحيفه في ظل دعم غربي متواصل لكييف
بالاسلحه كبديل لعضويه النيتو الفوريه ما
يعني تهديدا وجوديا لروسيا وهو ما يبدد ما
كان يعول عليه بوتين في تراجع الدعم
الغربي مع اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه
اكد رايس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه في ان
قواته لن توقع اي عقد مع وزير الدفاع
الروسيه
ان قرار وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الذي
اعلنتها امس بضروره قيام المتطوعين بتوقيع
عقود لا ينطبق على مقاتله مشددا على ان
باجنر لن توقع اي عقود مع شيكو
احدث الخلافات وليس اخرها في علاقه لا
طلاق فيها لكن قد ياتي الخلاف الاخير على
هذه الشراكه قائد مجموعه فاجنر بروجين
يرفض اوامر وزير الدفاع الروسي
امر الجميع وحدات المتطوعين بتوقيع عقود
مع وزارته بحلول نهايه الشهر في خطوه
لزياده فعاليه الجيش الروسي بيان وزاره
الدفاع وان لم يات على ذكر فاجنر الا ان
وسائل اعلام روسيه اعتبرت تلك الخطوه
محاوله من شايغو لاخضاع مقاتل فاجنر
لسيطرته
رفض توقيع اي عقود مع الشايغو واعتبر ان
القرار لا ينطبق على شركته
خلاف يعكس عمق الازمه بين الرجلين فبلغت
مبلغ كسر العظم على ما يبدو تلك ازمه في
سلسله متلاحقه من الاتهامات والشتائم
اطلقها
الصوره الماضيه ضد المؤسسه العسكريه وصلت
حد تخوين كل طرف للاخر ازمه العقود تزامنت
مع اخرى يريد ايضا فسخ عقد تموين مع وزاره
الدفاع بصفته مالك شركه كونكورد المورده
للجيش الروسي وجبات الطعام منذ عام 2006
وفي رساله لشايجو لجا الى هذا الخيار بسبب
مطالبه مسؤولين بوزاره الدفاع لشركته
بالتعاقد مع موردين جدد معتبرا تلك الخطوه
انفاقا غير خاضع للرقابه كما ان بعضهم
بحسب بروجين من دول غير صديقه لروسيا خروج
الطباخ الرئيسي الى العلم بعد سنوات من
العمل في الظل اصطدم بعدوات يقال انها
تزايدت بسبب طموحات قد تجعل مصيره خارج
مطبخ الكرملين
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على عوده 94
عسكريا روسيا من الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
كين وشار البيانو روسيا عوده الاسراجات
نتيجه عمليه تفاوض وان الاسرى كانوا
معرضين لخطر الموت في العصر
ربنا
[موسيقى]
سعيد مع ثلاثه من قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي
ملفات عده ابرزها مكافحه الهجره غير
النظاميه حيث اعلن عن تخصيص مئه مليون
يورو لتونس من اجل احتواء تدفق المهاجرين
نحو اوروبا هذا وشددت رئيسه الوزراء
الايطاليه
وان اي زعزعه للاستقرار فيها سيكون له
تداعيات خطيره على استقرار منطقه شمال
افريقيا باكملها
ونتداعيات ستصل ايضا الى ايطاليا
يفترشون الارض ويلتحفون السماء هنا صفاقس
التونسيه حيث لا حيله للمهاجرين غير
النظاميين سوى الانتظار ريثما تحين ساعه
النجده من هذه القوارب تبدا رحله تتضاءل
فيها فرص الحياه الوجهه ايطاليا لكن
العبور اليها قد ينذر بموت قادم ما زالت
تبكيه الامهات على الشواطئ
تتقاذفهم الامواج والبلدان فحتى قبل
ابحارهم يتناهى الى مسامعهم نباوا التصدي
لقدمهم تونس تلك الدوله التي تشكو ازمه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه بات يرهقها تدفقهم
مباحثات مشتركه مع زعماء ايطاليا وهولندا
والاتحاد الاوروبي تهدف الى تمهيد الطريق
لخطه انقاذ تونس ومعها كم المهاجرين هذا
اكثر من عشره الاف من الفرين والاعداد غير
دقيقه هكذا ترجح بيانات الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد بعد زياره مفاجئه لصفاقس التي
تعج بهم توسط فيها المهاجرين وبعد ان
استمع لبعض شكواهم اوضح ان بلاده ليست
بوابه حدوديه لاوروبا ولا يمكن ايضا ان
نقوم بالدور الذي
يفسح عنه البعض
ويخفيه البعض الاخر بان نكون حراسا
لدولهم لا الحل لا يمكن ان يكون الا
انسانيا وجمعيا بناء على مقاييس انسانيه
ولكن في ظل القانون
مشتركه لحل واحده من اطول الازمه السياسيه
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك بعد التوصل
لخطه مبدئيه لتقاسم مسؤوليتهم لكن قد تكون
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه
التي زارت تونس مرتين في اسبوع الطرف
الاشد في منعهم من ان تطا اقدامهم بلادها
اسراء الصغير العربيه
تتابعنا ايضا في هذه ولكن بعد الفا
السلطات المصريات تنتشر مركبا احترق قباله
ساحل البحر الاحمر وكان على بطنه ثلاثه
بريطانيا
اهلا بكم من جديد اظهرت نتائج استطلاع
اجره معهد ابسوس ان 47% من المشاركين يرون
ان تهم الوارده في قضيه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق ذات دوافع سياسيه فيما لا يعتقد
37% من القضايا تحمل تلك الدوافع
[موسيقى]
اعتبرت محاميه رئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب وحلفاء له ان الاحتفاظ
بمستندات بعد مغادره البيت الابيض بصفتها
تذكارات شخصيه او وثائق رفعت عنها سريه
كانت ضمن حقوقه الملاحقات السياسيه التي
يتعرض لها بدوره قال رئيس لجنه شؤون
القضائيه بمجلس النواب الجمهوري جيم جوردن
ان قدره الرئيس على التصنيف والتحكم في
الوصول الى معلومات الامن القومي مستمده
من الدستور
تصريحات ناريه التي اطلقها الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب في الايام الماضيه لا زالت
متفاعله فتهام ترامب ما اسمه اليسار
المتطرف باستخدام وزاره عدل فاسده ومكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي ووزير العدل ومدعين
عامين للتدخل في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله لم يمر مرور الكرام في الاوساط
السياسيه او الشعبيه
الاجابه الاولى على تصريحات ترامب اتت من
من عرف سابقا بالحليف المخلص بالبعر الذي
شغل منصب وزير العدل في اداره ترامب اجابه
ربما تنسف كل جهود ترامب لتحويل القضيه
لصالحه في منحه
اذا ما صحت نصف هذه الاتهامات فهو منتهم
تماما في قضايا سابقه هو مظلوم نعم ولكن
في هذه القضيه ابدا الان هناك اتهام
بالتجسس
وفي ظل هذا التراشق القانوني يبقى التراشق
السياسي سيد الموقف اذ سرع عدد من
الجمهوريين لدعم ترامب ضد لائحه الاتهامات
الاخيره ولعل ابرزهم طبعا السنه الجمهوريه
دعني اتكلم من غير المقبول توجيه هذه
التهم انا لا اقول انما فعله صحيح لكن لا
يمكننا محاسبته في الوقت الذي تم فيه
انتهاك العديد من القوانين من قبل
الديمقراطيين ومن قبل هيلر كلينتون تحديدا
ولم يحاسبهم احد
اما تعليقات ديمقراطيين فكانت رصينه وذات
نبره حازمه مثل تعليق السناتور
لا دليل ابدا على ان وزاره العدل قد تم
تسليحها لتوجيه هذه الاتهامات
استطاعات الراي اشارت الى ان حوالي 47% من
المشاركين يعتبرون هذه الاتهامات سياسيه
مقابل
37% وامام كل هذه التعقيدات القانونيه
تتجه الامطار الان الى رده فعل انصار
الرئيس السابق والخوف من اطلاق دعوات عنف
وتصعدا خاصه في يوم المحاكمه الاسبوع
المقبل ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن
هكذا تسلطاته في مدينه في الامريكيه سقوط
جزء من جسر على احد اكثر الطرق استخدام
شرق البلاد وذلك بعد اندلاع حريق واشارت
السلطات الى عدم وقوع ضحايا جراء الحادث
وفي اسطوره قالت الشرطه ان ما لا يقل عن
عشره اشخاص لقوا مصرعهم واصيب خمسه وعشرون
اخرون بعد انزلاق حافله كانت تقل ضيوف حفل
زفاف من منحدر في ولايه نيو ساوث ويلز
الاستراليه وقع الحادث على بعد حوالي 180
كيلومترا شمال غربي سيدني والقي القبض على
سائق الحافله الذي يبلغ من العمر 58 عاما
ومن المتوقع توجيه اتهامات له بشان الحادث
انتشرت سلطات المصريه ركاب السفينه وليخت
الذي احترق قباله ساحل البحر الاحمر بعد
ان قالت ان ثلاثه مواطنين بريطانيين فقدوا
بعد ان اشتعلت النيران في قارب غطس كانوا
على متنه قباله الساحل على البحر الاحمر
هذا فيما قالت محافظه البحر الاحمر ان
اثني عشر فردا من افراد الطاقم و12 سائحا
بريطانيا تم انقاذهم عندما اشتعلت النيران
في اليخت قباله مدينه
السابقه
له وذلك بعد ان القت القبض عليها في اطار
تحقيقات في شؤون الماليه للحزب الوطني
الحاكم المؤيد للاستقلال
اعلنت وزاره النقل العراقيه ابرام اتفاق
مع ايران لتنفيذ خط لسكك الحديديه لنقل
المسافرين بين مدينتي البصره وشلامامج
الايرانيه ونقلت وكاله الانباء العراقيه
عن بيان لوزاره النقل القول ان مشروع خط
السكك الحديديه يعد من المشاريع الحيويه
التي تربط البلدين ومن المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه والمستقبليه للسكك الحديديه
ضمن خطه النهوض بواقعها الخدمي والتشغيلي
اوضح البيان ان مشروع الربط السككي مع
ايران يتعلق بنقل المسافرين فقط
اثار تعيين الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
لابراهيم كان الرئيس لجهاز الاستخبارات
اهتماما في الشارع التركي لجهه التساؤل
حول درايته بالعمل الامني وخبايا لكن
مواهب كلن الاخرى كانت طوال الاسبوع
الماضي حديث الشارع التركي
تشكل اله الصاز تراثا موسيقيا في تركيا
فهي معشوقه الفنانين وكثير من الهواه
يفضلونها ولا يقتصر الاهتمام بها على
الفنانين فقط فهناك رياضيون وكتاب
وسياسيون ايضا برعوا في العزف على هذه
الاله الموسيقيه اوضحوا مثال على ذلك رئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات الجديد
يلا
تلقى اغاني ابراهيم كالين رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات الجديد صدى واسعا عند الجمهور
في تركيا فهو عازف ومغني محترف وكاتب
ومتخصص بالفكر الاسلامي والفلسفه شغفه
بالموسيقى والغناء لم يمنعه من احتراف
السياسه والعمل الامني فهو احد مستشارين
السياسيين والامنيين لاردوغان في السنوات
الماضيه
عملت مستشارا لابراهيم كالاند لمده خمسه
اعوام هو شخصيه متنوعه له عده نشاطات يهتم
بالفن وبالفلسفه والادب عمل كثيرا وبشكل
متصل مع رئيس الاستخبارات السابق هاكان
فيدان وكان من ضمن فريق النخبه الامنيه
والسياسيه للرئيس اردوغان انتقاله الى
جهاز الاستخبارات شكل مفاجاه للكثيرين لكن
المقربين منه ومن عمل معه يؤكدون انه على
درايه بمعظم الملفات الامنيه لذلك لم يكن
قرار تعيينه مفاجئا لهم
منذ عام 2018 وهو يعمل كرئيس للجنه سياسه
الخارجيه والامن في رئاسه الجمهوريه وهي
اللجنه التي عملت فيها مستشارا له وان لم
يكن له توصيف رسمي لكن السيد كالين كان
المستشار الاول للرئيس اردوغان في قضايا
الامن وسياسه الخارجيه ايضا كان وكيل
الرئيس في اداره لجنه الامن القومي
في استحقاق ابراهيم كالين الجديد لن يعزف
على اوتار السياسه وتقلباتها فقط بل هو
مطالب باداره ملفات امنيه اطلع عليها في
سابق عمله كمستشار وناطق اعلامي باسم
الرئاسه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
فالختام هذا تذكير بالعناوين
الرياض وهو واشنطن يتجدد العنف في انتهاء
الغده في السودان وترفضان الحل العسكري
للصراع
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه تطلب مجددا تمكين
خبرائها من الوصول لخزانات كخوفكا التي
تبرد محطه الزفر
واستطاع الراي يظهر ان سبعه واربعين
بالمئه من المشاركين يرون ان التهم
الوارده في قضيه رئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب ذات دوافع سياسي
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات